kloet blanchemaison bonjour bonjour
heureux de vous retrouver ce matin dans
la matinale de rtl france alors pour
bien comprendre pourquoi cette crise
politique aujourd'hui en colombie à
l'orgie de la crise il y à la loi
fiscale d'ubs du président colombien qui
voulaient étendre la base de la taxe à
la valeur ajoutée donc des impôts à yagg
est également étendre l'application de
l'impôt sur le revenu des personnes
physiques notamment pour des tranches
plus bas qu'habituellement
autrement dit une réforme fiscale qui
frapperait essentiellement la classe
moyenne et la classe moyenne dans ces
tranches dans ces tranches basses
ça c'est le début de la contestation
mais évidemment une fois une fois partie
la contestation s'est élargie
parce que le président veut également le
président de la colombie voudrait
également privatiser une partie du
secteur de la santé
et finalement la contestation s'étend à
sa politique de la santé à cette
politique de l'éducation et on voit une
prise en masse à la fois des syndicats
des jeunes des femmes qui ont été
particulièrement touchés par la crise du
coc vide c'est elle qui sont les plus
touchés par le chômage qui aujourd'hui
atteint 17 ou 19 pour cent en colombie
et puis également ce qu'on appelle et
les indigènes qui sont hostiles à la
politique du gouvernement qui pulvérise
par avion du glyphosate pour empêcher la
culture traditionnelle de la cola alors
tu le tout ça fait beaucoup de
mécontents à la dent dans l'ensemble du
pays et par conséquent la contestation
évidemment se répand avec des barrages
qui aboutissent au blocage que l'on
connaît aujourd'hui
alors un blocage et et beaucoup de
violence aussi claude un con qu'on peut
observer sur place encore 26
mort samedi selon les chiffres officiels
comment la comprendre cette violence il
ya une tradition colombienne de la delà
de la violence de la répression
et peut-être aussi des conditions dans
lesquelles le président du rrq et a été
élu ta jeune technocrate qui a été élu
en ligne à trois ans grâce au soutien du
président du d2 du wouri b et
préfectures mans pour faire une
politique que l'on pourrait qualifier
pour simplifier d'une politique de
droite
tous les deux étaient d'ailleurs hostile
à la conclusion de l'accord de paix avec
les farc
donc avec les les les aigus les
combattants qui a caves et des unités
militaires et cet accord avec les farc a
permis à la population d'espérer un
retour de la paix et de la fin la guerre
civile dans ce pays
d'ailleurs le président du rrq et montre
du doigt dans ces manifestations
actuelles
peut-être des infiltrations de
dissidents des farc qui avec quelques
éléments mafieux également contribuerez
à l'agitation élite et rien ne démontre
qu'il ya le thème d'infiltration et on
voit simplement qu'à police anti-émeute
utilisent des moyens très violent par
ailleurs on a vu à cali des véhicules 4
4 civils tiraient sur des indigènes
par conséquent sans doute aussi un
certain nombre de catégories de
propriétaires dans la dans la région
manifestent leur leur volonté de ramener
les indigènes comme on dit là-bas dans
leurs réserves
alors claude eux face à cette crise
sociale quelle est la réponse
aujourd'hui du gouvernement colombien et
il va de nos caisses on a vu sur votre
sujet dans votre sujet des tentatives de
dialogue simplement pour le président de
look et le dialogue ça consiste pour
l'essentiel à faire lever l'essai de 100
barrages qui existe qui résulte du fait
que les camionneurs se sont solidarisés
avec les syndicats et avec le mouvement
et il veut évidemment rétablir la
circulation et la vie normale dans le
pays les les routes d'approvisionnement
et pour cela il faut faire lever les
barrages qui existent sur les
principales routes donc avec la
vice-présidente ils tentent d'engager un
dialogue auquel il associe les
gouverneurs des provinces mais
manifestement hier le courant n'est pas
passé entre le président du rrq et les
syndicats et les gens qui dirigent la
contestation puisque c'est une
contestation qui va bien au delà du
sujet initial de la loi fiscale qui pour
le moment a été suspendu a été retiré
ils prétendent ok en présentera
naturellement une autre version dans
quelques semaines lorsque le calme sera
revenu mais il aura probablement
beaucoup de mal à ramener le calme
car il ne fait pas de véritables
concessions merci beaucoup que l'autre
branche maison pour ces précisions
l'édito diplo de la matinale c'est tous
les mardis matin à retrouver également
sur les réseaux sociaux